einmal selbst die ganze menschheit
vernichten das iphone zum qualmen
bringen oder den sternenhimmel auch
tagsüber beobachten die top five science
fcz zum science fiction und wieder aus
dem basket up studie in berlin
wollt ihr euer smartphone mal so richtig
zum glühen bringen
da gibt es eine app die das letzte aus
eurem prozessor holt auf der 15 stellt
euch freies wort hallo mein name ist
hirn und meine persönliche wissenschaft
lieblingstracks denn hiermit lassen sich
kunstwerke aus mathematischen
gleichungen erstellt auf dem ersten
blick denkt man an hintergrund bilder
und grafiken noch hinterfragt steck
komplizierte mathematik mit dieser app
kann man tief in die welt der fraktale
eintauchen die mathematische strukturen
durch gleichungen aufzeigen unsichtbar
machen können das bedeutet durch
mathematische berechnungen lassen sich
verschiedene grafiken linien und farben
erschaffen die auf fraktale basieren mit
verschiedenen bewegungen kann man in das
bild hinein zoomen oder bewegen grips in
worte zu fassen ist gar nicht so einfach
deshalb ladet euch die app herunter und
probiert es aus die app gibt es leider
nur für ios die nächste ist dafür
ausschließlich für android bitteschön
alexy vecsey die 4
wisst ihr meine persönliche schein sap
ist momentan ein fucking los scheint es
ist eine offizielle app zur homepage
life science punkt com
aber da gibt es noch mehr wisst ihr bei
der wissenschaft oder bei technologien
ist ja allgemein so ganz egal woran man
glaubt oder ganz egal wie man etwas
findet es ist trotzdem fakt was die
wissenschaft aufzeigt und diese r
fackellaufs 1 die unterstützt das noch
so richtig denn ganz egal worauf nicht
gerade der bahn
im auto als beifahrer natürlich oder
sonstwo lust habe ich kann direkt auf
themen zugreifen wie zum beispiel
raumfahrt betreffen umwelttechnologie
chemie oder oder und kaminen die
aktuellsten kuriosesten oder einfach nur
atemberaubend aus bereich wissenschaft
und techniker noch suchen und sind froh
versionen die kostet zwar 79 cent aber
kann das ganze dann auch offline
aufrufen und muss dann nicht für alle
geil nachrichten und bilder die ist er
zum beispiel zu dem neuen super
schwarzen material das dicke unsichtbar
machen kann theoretisch und sichtbar
machen kann datenvolumen verbraucht oder
kann es einmal mutterland ringo per wlan
im café und hat es sind immer bei mir
unterwegs in der tasche also performance
auswahlmöglichkeit und multimediale
ausstattung machte er einfach all of
science zu meinem neuen top begleiter
für unterwegs und das ist somit einer
der gründe warum ich wissenschaft
fucking nochmal liebe und noch eine app
die offline funktioniert die app der
klimaskeptiker skeptiker für ios und
android auf der 3 matthias von welotec
tivi stellt die woche die app die ich
euch kurz vorstellen möchten endlich
skeptikers heinz mit bingo zum thema
globaler klimawandel
es gibt zum beispiel einen top ten
thermometer der häufig genannten
argumente von skeptikern was eben diese
thematik angeht und dazu findet man dann
immer relativ kurz gehalten artikel die
von der community aufbereitet wurden das
ganze passiert wirklich auf
wissenschaftlichen arbeiten also man
nicht irgendwie so zu wissenschaftlich
sondern wirklich sehr interessant was
man findet im vergleich zur webseite
leider nur alles auf englisch verfügbar
auf der website gibt es mittlerweile
eine ganze menge auch auf deutsch
wiederum der vorteil hier wenn er zum
beispiel den flieger seit das ganze
funktioniert auch offline und auf der 2
der skyguide eine app für nachtschwärmer
also leute die gern die sterne am himmel
zählen und das können sie jetzt auch
tagsüber vorgestellt von thomas seinen
kanal alles für sich
als nächstes hätten wir skype apps von
google eine app mit der mit hilfe von
gps rausfinden könnt wo sich momentan
jegliche himmelskörper wie sterne oder
planeten befinden
in der app könnt ihr dann auch nach
galaxien oder planeten filtern
damit ihr auch genau das angezeigt
bekommt was ihr auch sehen wollt und wer
gerade keinen android handy besitzt
bekommt fast ja ich auch für ios und den
namen sky guide kostet zwar um die 180
dafür habt aber auch noch so manche
zusatzfeatures die app ist besonders für
die leute interessant die wissen wollen
was sie da gerade so am nachthimmel
sehen und eine nette spielerei ist es
auch noch in diesem fall eine klare
empfehlung von meiner seite und die
einst finde ich ziemlich beeindruckend
was dem kontext kaliber hat wie entdeckt
und sie nach stellt vier partien
schlechten tag gehabt und alles und
jeder macht euch gerade absolut ab wie
cool wäre es denn in einer welt zu leben
in der nur ihr lebt geht nicht geht doch
also auf jeden fall in digital mit der
simulation sap blecking könnt ihr
nämlich euren frust ablassen und
versuchen die komplette welt aus zu
löschen
rein theoretisch natürlich das ganze
nicht mit irgendwelchen 08 15 bomben
sondern mit solchen und biochemischen
kampfstoffen ihr wählt am anfang des
spiels zwischen verschiedenen solchen
typen wie bakterien viren pilzen oder
parasiten gebt euren menschheit
vernichten supervirus einnahmen und
sucht euch danach einen land aus von dem
sich eure krankheit verbreiten soll aber
vorsicht dabei es eure solche zu tödlich
und der erreger tötet alle seine wörter
obwohl noch nicht die gesamte welt
infiziert ist ist das spiel zu ende es
gibt bei black inc also einiges zu
beachten bevor die ganze welt dem
erdboden gleich gemacht haben auf dem
weg dahin wird eure solche mit realen
krankheiten zeitlichen euch wird
beispielsweise gesagt dass erreger nun
ansteckender ist als der hiv virus oder
schon mehr menschen daran gestorben sind
als einer besten hat auf jeden fall den
eindruck dass black inc ein recht nahe
an der realität programmierte spiel ist
die app sowohl für android als offene us
erhältlich und kostenlos beinhaltet
allerdings in dem käufer um alles frei
schalten zu können muss man aber nicht
zwingt man probiert doch einfach mal aus
ein virus heißt übrigens taxistand heim
und beginnt ein bisschen spielen cookies
buch ist schon ein bisschen an ebola ein
special habe ich aber noch tiefer ging
nach science gibt es nämlich ähnlich
auch auf deutsch es ist das war jetzt
nicht die robbe sondern ein kleiner
trommelwirbel für die klicks auch hier
gibt es täglich wissenschafts news alle
videos vom kanal twitter facebook
instagram und noch eine besonderheit die
zeit places überall wo er im
deutschsprachigen raum unterwegs seid
werden euch dort die spannendsten museen
erlebnisausstellung planetarien und
vieles mehr gezeigt check des aus hier
klicken
gibt es natürlich für android und ios
links wie immer auch eine video
beschreibung und hier geht es zu einem
super interessanten thema aliens in
unserem sonnensystem
wenn es euch gefallen hat abonnieren
nicht vergessen favorisieren
kommentieren
guckt euch aus und biss dann bleibt dran